This episode of 100 Objects is brought to you by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Claude is the AI for minds that don't stop at good enough. It's the collaborator that actually understands your entire workflow and thinks with you. Whether you're debugging code at midnight or strategizing your next business move, Claude extends your thinking to tackle the problems that matter. Build interactive tools and apps by describing what you need. Custom calculators, data visualization dashboards, even prototypes, all without writing a single line of code.
本期《100件物品》节目由Claude背后的团队Anthropic赞助。Claude是为那些不满足于“足够好”的头脑而设计的AI。它是一位真正理解你整个工作流程并与你共同思考的合作伙伴。无论你是在午夜调试代码，还是在为下一个商业决策制定战略，Claude都能扩展你的思维，助你解决重要问题。通过描述你的需求来构建交互式工具和应用程序。自定义计算器、数据可视化仪表板，甚至是原型，无需编写一行代码。
For problems worth solving, get started with Claude at claw.AI. That's claw.a.i. The year is 1988. After decades of political tensions, the Cold War is finally beginning to thaw out. But despite this, we start our story underground in a windowless room. It was literally called the bomb shelter. This is Terry Eldridge. It was a basement space, just this wide open room.
对于值得解决的问题，请访问claw.AI开始使用Claude。网址是claw.a.i。时间是1988年。经过几十年的政治紧张局势，冷战终于开始解冻。但尽管如此，我们的故事还是从地下一个没有窗户的房间开始。它真的被称为“防空洞”。这是特里·埃尔德里奇（Terry Eldridge）。那是一个地下室空间，就是一个宽敞的空房间。
room. On this particular winter afternoon, Terry found himself hunkered down in the bomb shelter, but he wasn't taking cover from an incoming missile or nuclear fallout. The bomb shelter was just a rec room in a dorm where Terry went to college. He and some classmates had gathered there because Terry had recently received a phone call from his dad, Roy. And he told Terry to make sure he was going to be near a TV in just a few days' time, because something really good was going to be on. Over $76,000 just waiting to be won today on Wheel of Fortune. And now here's your host.
房间。在这个特别的冬日下午，特里发现自己蜷缩在防空洞里，但他并不是在躲避来袭的导弹或核辐射。这个防空洞只是特里上大学时宿舍里的一个娱乐室。他和一些同学聚在那里，因为特里最近接到了他父亲罗伊（Roy）的电话。他告诉特里，一定要确保在几天后待在电视机旁，因为会有非常精彩的节目播出。今天在《幸运轮》（Wheel of Fortune）节目中，有超过76,000美元等着被赢走。现在，有请我们的主持人。
Me and a bunch of friends sat and watched my dad on Wheel of Fortune and it was really surreal. Did it surprise you to learn that he was going to be on TV? Was this out of character for him? Oh, absolutely. He was a retired cop. He had been a Denver cop for years. Roy Eldridge from Broomfield, Colorado. What do you do back there?
我和一群朋友坐在一起看我爸爸上《幸运轮》，那感觉真的很超现实。得知他要上电视，你感到惊讶吗？这对他来说反常吗？哦，绝对反常。他是一名退休警察。他当了多年的丹佛警察。来自科罗拉多州布鲁姆菲尔德的罗伊·埃尔德里奇。你在那儿做什么工作？
I'm Chief Physical Security for a large government facility. Uh-huh. Sounds kind of secretive, Roy. Not really. Oh, all right. It turns out Terry's dad was good at the game. Roy was the biggest earner of the day and qualified to play the bonus round for a pretty sweet prize. Roy, you're going to be playing for the Jeep Wrangler Open Air Model with room for four.
我是大型政府设施的首席物理安全官。嗯哼。听起来挺神秘的，罗伊。其实不然。哦，好吧。事实证明，特里的父亲很擅长这个游戏。罗伊是当天赢钱最多的人，并获得了参加奖金回合的资格，可以赢取一份相当不错的奖品。罗伊，你将要为这辆有四个座位、敞篷款的吉普牧马人而战。
Retail value $12,765. He won this beautiful red Jeep Wrangler. 15 seconds to talk it out. Good luck. Maternity leave. I knew you could. And I'm thinking, you've got this 19 or 20-year-old kid in college. You don't need a Jeep Wrangler, but I would love one. I was so excited thinking, I am getting a Jeep. Terry wouldn't get the Jeep. But there was another thing. At the time, Wheel of Fortune had a segment called The Shopping Round. You got there by spinning the wheel, of course, solving the podcast. and hopefully winning thousands of dollars.
零售价12,765美元。他赢得了这辆漂亮的红色吉普牧马人。有15秒的时间商量。祝你好运。产假。我知道你能行。我在想，你是一个19或20岁的大学生。你不需要吉普牧马人，但我很想要一个。我当时太兴奋了，心想，我要得到一辆吉普车了。特里最终没能得到那辆吉普车。但还有另一件事。当时，《幸运轮》有一个环节叫“购物回合”。当然，你是通过转动转盘、解开谜题来到这里的，并希望能赢取数千美元。
But you didn't get to take any of that cash home. Instead, contestants had to spend it all right there during the shopping round, where they forced you to buy random things that filled the stage. Jet skis, vacation packages, you got whatever you could afford. And every episode, the announcer would hype up those very prizes that you'd been forced to buy. My dad bought these horrible gold-plated sunglasses. The Cazale 951 sports system, sunglasses, in an attractive presentation. That looked like something straight out of the Elvis wardrobe.
但你不能把那些现金带回家。相反，参赛者必须在购物回合中把钱全部花掉，节目组强迫你购买填满舞台的随机物品。摩托艇、度假套餐，你能买得起什么就买什么。每一集，播音员都会大肆宣传那些你被迫购买的奖品。我爸爸买了这些可怕的镀金太阳镜。Cazale 951运动系统，太阳镜，精美包装。看起来就像直接从猫王（Elvis）的衣柜里拿出来的一样。
Retail value, $300. And he also bought what at the time was a very pretty crystal peacock. Crystal, large peacock, handcraft of the finest, 32% lead Austrian crystal, $800. Towards the end of the round, once people got down to less than $200, there wasn't much left to buy. except for for about $150, there was always this ceramic dog. Top honors go to our favorite mascot. Wheel of Fortune's ceramic Dalmatian, a medium-sized dog we've all learned to love. $154.
零售价300美元。他还买了一只当时看起来非常漂亮的晶体孔雀。晶体，大型孔雀，由最优质的32%铅奥地利水晶手工制作，800美元。在这一轮快结束时，一旦人们剩下的钱不到200美元，就没剩下什么可买的了。除了大约150美元的这只陶瓷狗。最高荣誉归于我们最喜欢的吉祥物。《幸运轮》的陶瓷大麦町犬，我们都学会喜爱的一只中型狗。154美元。
A life-sized black-and-white polka dot dog made out of baked clay. It was kind of a consolation prize. Here's what you get with whatever money you have left that isn't a number. to buy anything else on the set except for this dog. It was truly just the thing you got when you couldn't afford anything else. Terry doesn't even really remember seeing his dad buy one, but he did. And like so many people who went on Wheel of Fortune in the 1980s, a ceramic Dalmatian ended up back at Roy's house.
一只真人大小的黑白波点狗，由陶土制成。这算是一种安慰奖。这就是你剩下的钱买不到任何其他东西时能得到的东西。特里甚至不记得他爸爸买过这只狗，但他确实买了。就像许多在20世纪80年代参加《幸运轮》的人一样，一只陶瓷大麦町犬最终回到了罗伊的家里。
After the excitement of watching his dad on Wheel of Fortune, Terry finished college, moved, bought a home, got married, and started a family of his own. His father kept the dog all that time, and then one day he pulled Terry aside. And he said, hey, take the dog home with you. So he has sat in our house guarding the top of the stairs for the past 20-plus years. Thanks to his dad, Terry is the proud owner of perhaps the ultimate useless object. The Wheel of Fortune ceramic Dalmatian has no discernible purpose whatsoever. functionally, nothing would change in Terry's life if he got rid of it, but he insists he never, ever will.
在看完他爸爸上《幸运轮》的兴奋之后，特里大学毕业、搬家、买了房、结了婚，并组建了自己的家庭。他父亲一直留着那只狗，直到有一天他把特里拉到一边。他说，嘿，把这只狗带回家吧。所以它在过去20多年里一直坐在我们家楼梯顶上守着。多亏了他父亲，特里成了这件或许是终极无用之物的骄傲拥有者。《幸运轮》的陶瓷大麦町犬没有任何可辨别的用途。从功能上讲，如果特里把它扔掉，他的生活不会有任何改变，但他坚持说他永远、永远不会这样做。
And it's not just beloved to Terry. For a brief moment, it became the mascot for one of America's most popular game shows, appearing on tens of millions of TV screens, night after night, all across the country. If you watched Wheel of Fortune in the 1980s, I bet you big money you remember the ceramic Dalmatian. But why did this fake, useless dog capture the fleeting attention of our nation? From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States in 100 Objects. I'm Roman Mars. And today, why the Wheel of Fortune ceramic Dalmatian is the perfect symbol of the game show,
而且它不仅深受特里的喜爱。在短暂的一段时间里，它成为了美国最受欢迎的游戏节目之一的吉祥物，每晚在全国数千万台电视屏幕上出现。如果你在20世纪80年代看过《幸运轮》，我敢打赌你一定记得那只陶瓷大麦町犬。但为什么这只虚假的、无用的狗抓住了我们国家短暂的注意力？来自99% Invisible和BBC Studios，这是《100件物品中的美国史》。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。今天，为什么《幸运轮》的陶瓷大麦町犬是游戏节目的完美象征，
and what the fascinating history of game shows and game show prizes tells us about the changing definition of the American dream. One of the things that fascinates me about game shows is the prizes. I've probably seen thousands of hours of game shows in my life. Growing up, I remember skipping school to watch Wheel of Fortune or The Price is Right, but I wasn't just into solving puzzles or guessing the price of a bottle of dish soap. Like millions of other Americans watching along with me, I wanted to see the stuff people won. Prizes are central to a game show.
以及游戏节目的迷人历史和奖品如何告诉我们关于美国梦定义的变化。关于游戏节目，最让我着迷的事情之一就是奖品。我这辈子可能看过几千小时的游戏节目。成长过程中，我记得逃学去看《幸运轮》或《价格猜猜猜》（The Price is Right），但我不仅仅是为了解谜或猜测一瓶洗洁精的价格。像数百万和我一起观看的美国人一样，我想看看人们赢到的东西。奖品是游戏节目的核心。
They are the reason viewers keep tuning in, imagining we could be the ones driving home in that brand new car. And those prizes have been there since the very start, before they were even called game shows. As far as we know, the quiz show is an American invention. It appears that the first one on the air was a show on the radio around 1924 called Brooklyn Daily Eagle Quiz on Current Events. Catchy.
它们是观众持续收看的原因，想象着我们可能是那个开着那辆崭新汽车回家的人。这些奖品从一开始就存在了，甚至在它们被称为“游戏节目”之前。据我们所知，问答节目是一项美国发明。看来第一个播出的节目是1924年左右在广播电台播出的《布鲁克林每日鹰报时事问答》。朗朗上口。
Rolls right off the tongue. This is Adam Neediff. author, historian, and researcher for the National Archives of Game Show History. The Brooklyn Daily Eagle was a newspaper in New York, and they had these events called current events bees. These events were kind of like a spelling bee for topical issues. Give a correct answer, you stayed in the contest, and the final person standing won both bragging rights and a small cash prize.
脱口而出。这是亚当·尼迪夫（Adam Neediff），作家、历史学家，也是国家游戏节目历史档案馆的研究员。《布鲁克林每日鹰报》是纽约的一份报纸，他们举办过名为“时事竞赛”的活动。这些活动有点像针对时事话题的拼字比赛。给出正确答案，你就能留在比赛中，最后胜出的人既赢得了吹牛的权利，也赢得了小额现金奖励。
And whenever Brooklyn Daily Eagle ran a current events bee, they would run a special edition of the paper where they printed all of the questions. and all of the correct answers and always sold a lot of extra copies. So Brooklyn Daily Eagle had the idea that, hey, we can sell copies of the paper with these things. Let's start putting the current events be on radio. So that was the idea originally. The first game show was invented to sell newspapers. Around the same time, another radio show emerged called Vox Pop.
每当《布鲁克林每日鹰报》举办时事竞赛时，他们就会发行一份特别版的报纸，上面印有所有的问题和所有正确的答案，总是能多卖出很多份。所以《布鲁克林每日鹰报》有了个想法，嘿，我们可以通过这些东西来卖报纸。让我们开始在广播里播放时事竞赛吧。所以这最初就是那个想法。第一个游戏节目是为了卖报纸而发明的。大约在同一时间，另一个广播节目出现了，叫《大众之声》（Vox Pop）。
It started out with hosts asking random people on the street their opinions on things happening in the news. Do you read the paper today? Well, I got about halfway through it. You did. Well, that's fine. I'm going to see how well you did about it. And eventually they came upon the idea. Let's do a segment of the show where we see what people actually know about these subjects. We'll ask them questions about what's going on in the news. I want you to give me three prominent items that were featured in the newspapers this week. And people didn't want to participate in this segment because they didn't want to risk looking foolish on the radio.
它最初是由主持人询问街上的随机路人对新闻中发生的事情的看法。你今天看报纸了吗？嗯，我看了大约一半。你看完了。好吧，那很好。我要看看你对它了解多少。最终他们想到了一个主意。让我们在节目中增加一个环节，看看人们对这些主题到底了解多少。我们会问他们关于新闻中正在发生的事情的问题。我希望你给我列出本周报纸上报道的三个重要项目。人们不想参加这个环节，因为他们不想冒在广播里看起来很愚蠢的风险。
So the hosts had this idea, well, let's take a lot of money with us. And we'll give people a dollar if they give the correct answer. Look at this dollar. Don't you want that dollar? All right. Here's one for each correct answer. A single dollar for a correct answer was all the incentive many needed. After all, this was the middle of the Great Depression. Quiz shows quickly became a potent form of distraction. Swaths of listeners who couldn't afford other entertainment could fantasize about winning a dollar for knowing a factor to.
所以主持人想到了一个主意，好吧，让我们带上很多钱。如果人们给出正确答案，我们就给他们一美元。看看这一美元。你不想得到那一美元吗？好吧。每个正确答案给一美元。对于许多人来说，一个正确答案换取一美元就是他们所需要的全部动力。毕竟，这正处于大萧条时期。问答节目很快成为了一种强有力的消遣方式。大批买不起其他娱乐活动的听众可以幻想通过了解一两个事实来赢得一美元。
These first quiz shows were also the perfect snapshot of a quintessentially American idea. If you applied yourself and you were smart, you could really achieve something, like winning a cash prize. These shows were always modest affairs. During World War II, the Fed's actually asked a lot of the shows to shut down for fear that an audience member would leak war secrets live on the air. But a few quiz shows stuck around, like one called Information Please, where the prizes included a $25 defense bond, practical and patriotic.
这些早期的问答节目也是一个典型的美国理念的完美缩影。如果你努力工作并且聪明，你真的可以取得成就，比如赢得现金奖励。这些节目一直都是小规模的。二战期间，联邦政府实际上要求许多节目停播，因为担心观众会在直播中泄露战争机密。但一些问答节目留了下来，比如一个叫《请回答》（Information Please）的节目，奖品包括25美元的国防债券，既实用又爱国。
Then the war ended. Quiz shows had never been about big games. giveaways anyways. The idea of, boy, wouldn't it be great to win on a quiz show? That would solve all my problems. No, that never happened until the end of World War II when all of a sudden they turned on the money faucet. That money faucet would change quiz shows forever. And it started thanks to the post-war boom in manufacturing. Word needed get out that goods were being produced again. And so that led to big giveaways on radio because giving away your furniture or your appliances from your factory was a good way to let Americans know, hey, we're up and running full speed again. We have so many things
然后战争结束了。无论如何，问答节目从来都不是为了大额赠品。那种“天哪，在问答节目中获胜不是太棒了吗？那将解决我所有的问题”的想法，不，直到二战结束，他们突然打开了金钱水龙头，这种情况才发生。那个金钱水龙头将永远改变问答节目。这要归功于战后的制造业繁荣。需要让人们知道商品又开始生产了。因此，这导致了广播中的大额赠品，因为赠送工厂的家具或电器是让美国人知道“嘿，我们又全速运转了”的好方法。我们有太多的东西
coming out of our factory that we can just give away a refrigerator on this radio show. So, you know, go out and buy a refrigerator this weekend at the department store. As a nation, the U.S. was becoming increasingly more wealthy. Not only could more people now afford consumer goods, they wanted them. Keeping up with the Joneses really became a big deal with the end of World War II. There was this dream that you were being sold of it's not just about being able to provide for your family. It's about having nice stuff for your family. And quiz shows had evolved
从我们的工厂生产出来，以至于我们可以在这个广播节目中直接赠送一台冰箱。所以，你知道，这个周末去百货商店买台冰箱吧。作为一个国家，美国变得越来越富有。现在不仅更多的人买得起消费品，他们还想要这些东西。二战结束后，“攀比”（Keeping up with the Joneses）确实成了一件大事。你被兜售着这样一个梦想：这不仅仅是关于能够养活你的家庭。而是关于为你的家庭拥有好的东西。而问答节目已经演变
to a point where they suddenly fit into that American dream. At the same time that Americans are trying to acquire stuff, that's when the quiz shows all of a sudden are giving stuff away in massive quantities. So these radio shows evolved in the same direction that the country at
到了一个它们突然融入美国梦的地步。在美国家庭试图获取物品的同时，问答节目也突然开始大量赠送物品。所以这些广播节目朝着国家发展的方向演变。
large was evolving. Quiz shows became a kind of mirror of American society. As consumer culture took off, quiz shows became more and more popular. What had started 30 years before as a way to sell some newspapers was exploding into a full-blown American phenomenon. TV played a huge role in this, turning the radio quiz show into a visual spectacle with dramatic studio lighting, on-screen countdowns, and glitzy sets. But it wasn't just the over-the-top production that made these quiz shows so
大体上在演变。问答节目成了美国社会的一面镜子。随着消费文化的兴起，问答节目变得越来越受欢迎。30年前作为卖报纸手段开始的东西，正在演变成一个全面的美国现象。电视在其中发挥了巨大作用，将广播问答节目变成了视觉奇观，配有戏剧性的演播室灯光、屏幕倒计时和华丽的布景。但不仅仅是夸张的制作让这些问答节目如此
successful. Many of them continued to push that core American value that you can have all the stuff you want, you can get that American dream by working hard and using your own wits. A new program called itself the show where, quote, knowledge is king and the reward is king's size. You see, as everything else got bigger, more shows, wider audiences, bigger sponsors, the prizes they were offering grew too. And those king size rewards, they were literally a thousand times bigger than what had come before. Take It or Leave It, presented by the makers of Ever Sharp Skyline Pens. The explosion of massive cash prizes began in the 1950s when a producer named Lewis Cohen
成功。其中许多节目继续推崇那个核心的美国价值观：你可以拥有你想要的所有东西，你可以通过努力工作和运用自己的智慧来实现那个美国梦。一个新节目自称是“知识为王，奖励为王”的节目。你看，随着其他一切变得更大，更多的节目、更广泛的受众、更大的赞助商，他们提供的奖品也随之增长。那些国王级的奖励，实际上比以前的大了一千倍。《拿走还是留下》（Take It or Leave It），由Ever Sharp Skyline钢笔制造商呈现。大规模现金奖励的爆炸式增长始于20世纪50年代，当时一位名叫刘易斯·科恩（Lewis Cohen）的制片人
decided to reimagine a hit radio quiz show called Take It or Leave It. The most exciting game you ever play, the game that doubles an interest with every question asked. At the heart of Take It or Leave It was the $64 question, an opportunity for contestants to gamble the $32 they had already won for $64. if they could successfully answer the hardest category of question on the show. Would you like to take your 32? That's a lot of money. I'll go for it. You'll go to 64.
决定重新构思一个名为《拿走还是留下》的热门广播问答节目。你玩过的最刺激的游戏，随着每一个问题的提出，兴趣倍增的游戏。《拿走还是留下》的核心是64美元的问题，这是一个让参赛者赌上他们已经赢得的32美元去赢取64美元的机会，如果他们能成功回答节目中最难的问题类别的话。你想拿走你的32美元吗？那是一大笔钱。我会去挑战。你会去挑战64美元。
But in his version, which would be made for TV, Lewis Cohen wanted to raise the stakes considerably. And so he pitched a new show called The $64,000 question. The $64,000 question is the monster hit of television in 19,000. And of course, imitation is the sincerest form of television. So the shows that are already on the air start introducing big money elements. In tonight's super bonus on Beat the Clock. Beat the Clock introduces the Super Bonus stunt, which is worth $64,000 or even more. And now Free Zone present.
但在他为电视制作的版本中，刘易斯·科恩想要大幅提高赌注。于是他推出了一个名为《64,000美元问题》（The $64,000 Question）的新节目。《64,000美元问题》是1958年电视界的超级热门节目。当然，模仿是电视界最真诚的奉承。所以已经在播出的节目开始引入大额金钱元素。在今晚《打败时钟》（Beat the Clock）的超级奖金中。《打败时钟》引入了超级奖金特技，价值64,000美元甚至更多。现在Free Zone呈现。
Name That Tune. The grand prize on Name That Tune had been $1,600. And all of a sudden, they're offering $25,000. Suddenly, quiz shows were offering way more money than they ever had. But the people who were actually paying for these massive prizes still wanted a return on their investment. In fact, they expected bigger returns than ever. And to guarantee big returns, these shows look to replicate what was already working elsewhere. The $64,000 question is a big hit show and it has an isolation booth.
《说出那首歌》（Name That Tune）。《说出那首歌》的大奖曾是1,600美元。突然之间，他们开始提供25,000美元。突然间，问答节目提供的钱比以往任何时候都多。但那些真正为这些巨额奖品买单的人仍然想要投资回报。事实上，他们期望比以往任何时候都更高的回报。为了保证高回报，这些节目寻求复制在其他地方已经行之有效的东西。《64,000美元问题》是一个大热门节目，它有一个隔离室。
So producers Jack Berry and Dan Nand Wright have this idea. let's do a quiz show with two isolation booths. Good evening. This is the television program called 21, and my name is Jack Barry. The premise of 21 was simple. Two contestants answered tribute questions in isolation booths. Neither of them knew how the other one was doing. Questions were worth up to 11 points each.
所以制片人杰克·巴里（Jack Barry）和丹·恩赖特（Dan Enright）有了个主意：让我们做一个有两个隔离室的问答节目。晚上好。这是名为《21点》（21）的电视节目，我的名字是杰克·巴里。《21点》的前提很简单。两名参赛者在隔离室中回答知识问答。他们谁都不知道对方表现如何。问题最高价值11分。
Whoever got the closest to 21 without going over, one. It's basically Blackjack mixed with your standard issue general knowledge quiz. Gentlemen, welcome back. Back to 21, that thunderous reception from our studio audience indicates that both of you are well-liked and having a hard job deciding who they want to win or lose on this program. As 21 became more successful, the producers wanted to do more with the show than just build dazzling sets and give away insane cash prizes. They wanted to push the boundaries of what defined a quiz show by elevating the average
谁最接近21点且不超过，谁就赢了。这基本上是二十一点游戏与标准常识问答的结合。先生们，欢迎回到《21点》，演播室观众雷鸣般的掌声表明你们俩都很受欢迎，他们很难决定在这个节目中希望谁赢谁输。《21点》变得越来越成功，制片人想在节目中做更多的事情，而不仅仅是搭建炫目的布景和赠送疯狂的现金奖励。他们想通过提升平均水平来突破定义问答节目的界限
Americans that you'd see on these programs and making the contestants larger than life. Dan Enright kind of cast his contestants, not cast them just in the sense that game shows cast contestants now, which is, oh, these people have engaging personalities that you want to see on television. No, Dan Enright would actually cast contestants as in they were characters to him. Enright was casting 21 as if it was a movie. In every good movie needs a star. For 10 points, name the second, third, fourth, and fifth wives of a movie. Henry the 8th and describe their faith. The producers found that star in a contestant named Charles Van Doren. Oh, my goodness.
你在这些节目中看到的美国人，并让参赛者变得比生活本身更伟大。丹·恩赖特有点像是在选角他的参赛者，不是现在游戏节目选角的那种意义，即“哦，这些人有吸引人的个性，你想在电视上看到他们”。不，丹·恩赖特实际上是在选角参赛者，因为对他来说他们是角色。恩赖特把《21点》当作电影来选角。10分，说出电影中亨利八世的第二、第三、第四和第五任妻子的名字，并描述她们的命运。制片人发现了一位名叫查尔斯·范多伦（Charles Van Doren）的参赛者，他就是那位明星。哦，天哪。
You want me to name the second, third, fourth, fifth wives, and what happened to all of them? That's right. I'll have to think a minute. Charles Van Doren was from a very famous family. His relatives were authors and poets and critics and professors. And Van Doren himself is a professor, very good. good-looking guy, incredibly charismatic, incredibly engaging, incredibly likable. Charlie, incidentally, I've had a lot of questions about you.
你要我列出第二、第三、第四、第五任妻子的名字，并说出她们都发生了什么？没错。我得想一分钟。查尔斯·范多伦来自一个非常著名的家庭。他的亲戚都是作家、诗人和评论家、教授。范多伦本人也是一位教授，非常好。长相帅气，非常有魅力，非常有吸引力，非常讨人喜欢。顺便说一句，查理，我收到很多关于你的问题。
Well, whether or not you're married or single. I'm single. You are, eh? And along with all that charisma and those good looks, Van Doren was intelligent, too. So intelligent, in fact, that he went on a winning streak that lasted 14 weeks. Our current winner, Charles Van Doren, has so far. far won $46,500. In just a moment, Mr. Van Doren can conceivably bring his total winnings up to $88,500.
嗯，关于你是否结婚或单身。我是单身。是吗，嗯？除了所有的魅力和英俊的外表，范多伦也很聪明。事实上，他非常聪明，以至于他创下了持续14周的连胜纪录。我们目前的获胜者查尔斯·范多伦到目前为止。已经赢得了46,500美元。再过一会儿，范多伦先生可能总共赢得88,500美元。
Van Doren's winning street catapulted him from an Ivy League English lecturer to national TV celebrity. Charles Van Doren makes the cover of Time magazine. Charles Van Doren makes the cover of TV guide. Charles Van Doren becomes a star in a way that quiz show contestants don't normally become stars. It was like a fairy tale. The charming, handsome, intelligent academic plucked out of obscurity and transformed into a national superstar.
范多伦的连胜让他从一名常春藤盟校的英语讲师变成了全国性的电视名人。查尔斯·范多伦登上了《时代》周刊的封面。查尔斯·范多伦登上了《电视指南》的封面。查尔斯·范多伦以一种问答节目参赛者通常不会成为明星的方式成为了明星。这就像一个童话故事。迷人、英俊、聪明的学者从默默无闻中被挖掘出来，变成了全国性的超级巨星。
In fact, it was a little too much like a fairy tale. This show was totally rigged. Charles Van Doren didn't win 14 straight weeks in a row, at least not legitimately. The producers of 21 had hands selected him as their champion before he even went on the air. They told Van Doren, and all the other previous hand-picked winners
事实上，这太像童话故事了。这个节目完全是作弊的。查尔斯·范多伦并没有连续赢14周，至少不是合法地赢的。《21点》的制片人在他上节目之前就已经选定他作为冠军了。他们告诉范多伦，以及所有其他之前被内定好的获胜者
all of the answers ahead of time. And this wasn't just 21 in Van Doren. Pretty much all of the big money quizzes in the late 50s, not all of them, but the vast majority of them were fixed. But at some point, to keep the drama going and viewers hooked wanting more, even hand-picked winners had to eventually lose.
提前告知了所有答案。这不仅仅是《21点》和范多伦。50年代末几乎所有的大额奖金问答节目，不是全部，但绝大多数都是作弊的。但在某个时候，为了保持戏剧性并让观众着迷，即使是内定的获胜者最终也必须输掉比赛。
And the producers of 21 were deciding that too. Not only did they tell him to throw the match, but how and on which question. But Van Doren had been such a success that NBC didn't want to let him go. When he was set to lose and leave 21, NBC decided to find him another gig that would keep him on the network.
《21点》的制片人也决定了这一点。他们不仅告诉他要输掉比赛，还告诉他如何输以及在哪个问题上输。但范多伦太成功了，NBC不想让他离开。当他准备输掉比赛并离开《21点》时，NBC决定为他找另一份工作，让他留在电视网。
They made him what they called the cultural correspondent for the today show. But not everybody was happy about this. Previous contestants were looking at Charles Van Dorn's soft landing and thinking, hang on, where was my television gig after I agreed to lose? These were just everyday people. and you can pull them off the street and say,
他们让他担任了他们所谓的《今日秀》（Today Show）的文化通讯员。但并不是每个人都对这个结果感到高兴。之前的参赛者看着查尔斯·范多伦的软着陆，心想，等等，我同意输掉比赛后，我的电视工作在哪里？这些人只是普通人。你可以把他们从街上拉过来，然后说，
you can't tell anybody what we're doing. You've got to keep this a secret. You can tell people that, but realistically, they're going to tell their spouse, they're going to tell their best friend for every one contestant that you rig, five people are going to find out
你不能告诉任何人我们在做什么。你必须保守这个秘密。你可以告诉人们，但现实中，他们会告诉他们的配偶，他们会告诉他们最好的朋友。你每作弊一个参赛者，就会有五个人发现
what's happening behind the scenes. And when you have this many shows that are operating this way, it's only a matter of time before the word gets out. And word did eventually get out. In August of 1958, the successful quiz show Dotto,
幕后发生了什么。当你有很多节目以这种方式运作时，消息传出去只是时间问题。消息最终确实传出去了。1958年8月，成功的问答节目《Dotto》，
was unceremoniously yanked off the air, and for days nobody knew why. And then the press got word of a story. A few months earlier, a man who was due to appear on the show found another contestant's notebook backstage. It was filled with all the answers for that evening show, answers to questions she couldn't have known yet. The contestant who found the notebook leaked it to the papers. And here's the thing.
被毫无预兆地停播了，几天来没人知道原因。然后媒体得到了一个消息。几个月前，一名本应出现在节目中的人在后台发现了另一名参赛者的笔记本。里面写满了当晚节目的所有答案，那些她不可能提前知道的问题的答案。发现笔记本的参赛者将其泄露给了报纸。事情就是这样。
Technically, rigging a game show wasn't illegal, as in there weren't really any laws that said you couldn't. But that technicality didn't stop the scandal from dividing the public. As the news that quiz shows were being investigated got out, many were upset and felt they had been deceived. The reaction to rigged quiz shows was so great that federal lawmakers started to investigate. In the Senate hearing room, the dramatic climax of the probe of fixed and rigged quiz shows. I mean, it is pretty amazing to think of Congress getting involved in quiz shows. And what do you think that says about how important they are and that the presentation is truthful? You know, there's a cynical answer in why Congress wanted to be involved with the quiz show scandals, which basically 1958 was a re-election year.
从技术上讲，操纵游戏节目并不违法，因为并没有真正的法律规定你不能这样做。但那个技术细节并没有阻止丑闻分裂公众。随着问答节目正在接受调查的消息传出，许多人感到愤怒并觉得他们受到了欺骗。对作弊问答节目的反应如此之大，以至于联邦立法者开始进行调查。在参议院听证室，针对固定和作弊问答节目的调查达到了戏剧性的高潮。我的意思是，想到国会介入问答节目真是太令人惊讶了。你认为这说明了它们有多重要，以及展示的真实性有多重要？你知道，对于国会为什么想介入问答节目丑闻，有一个愤世嫉俗的答案，基本上1958年是改选年。
So the idea of having something to police was a good look for the congressmen who were up for re-election. And Charles Van Doren was at the center of those congressional hearings. Charles Van Doren arrives to apologize and attempt to explain to the millions whose friendship and respect he had won. What really tipped the scales was a letter that I got from a woman who'd seen me on today. And in it, she said, you must, in order to live with yourself, tell the truth. That's the only way a man can live is with the truth. As a result of the congressional hearings, Van Dorn was fired from NBC and forced to leave his job at Columbia University. He had gone from celebrity to the face of a scandal.
所以有一个可以监管的对象对那些面临改选的国会议员来说是个好形象。查尔斯·范多伦处于那些国会听证会的中心。查尔斯·范多伦赶来道歉，并试图向数百万赢得了他友谊和尊重的人解释。真正让天平倾斜的是我从一位在《今日秀》上看到我的女士那里收到的一封信。信中她说，为了问心无愧，你必须说出真相。这是一个人能活下去的唯一方式，那就是面对真相。作为国会听证会的结果，范多伦被NBC解雇，并被迫离开他在哥伦比亚大学的工作。他从名人变成了丑闻的代言人。
He would never escape. As for the TV programs themselves, after dazzling us with the drama of impossible questions, charismatic contestants, incredible feats of human intelligence, and giant cash prizes, the era of the great American quiz show was over. All these shows, $64,000 question, 21,
他永远无法逃脱。至于电视节目本身，在用不可能的问题、有魅力的参赛者、令人难以置信的人类智慧壮举和巨额现金奖励让我们眼花缭乱之后，伟大的美国问答节目时代结束了。所有这些节目，《64,000美元问题》、《21点》，
Dotto, all of these rig quiz shows are off the air by the autumn of 1958. because, okay, now we have our proof that these quiz shows rig. Maybe the worst part of all this was the scandals left many of us kind of brokenhearted. I think it does say something about quiz shows that people were this upset. The American public was hurt to learn that this stuff wasn't real. A lot of that hurt came from the fact that the story quiz show fans had been sold, that the most knowledgeable, hardest working person would win the game. That story was a lie.
《Dotto》，所有这些作弊的问答节目在1958年秋天之前都停播了。因为，好吧，现在我们有了这些问答节目作弊的证据。也许这一切中最糟糕的部分是丑闻让许多人感到心碎。我认为人们如此愤怒确实说明了问答节目的一些问题。美国公众得知这些东西不是真的，感到很受伤。很多伤害来自于问答节目粉丝被兜售的故事，即知识最渊博、最努力工作的人会赢得比赛。那个故事是个谎言。
And in the wake of the scandals, everything about quiz shows seemed tainted. All of a sudden, you needed to come up with new ideas for what to do on these shows. And quiz was a dirty word. It had this negative connotation, which is how we ended up with the term game show. These game shows that weren't quizzes became popular in the 1960s. And you started looking for other things that people can do to win money. This wasn't just a rebrand. It was a whole new approach to the format. The chance to win simply with quiz show-style book smarts, that was out. Instead, these new game shows relied on motor skills, everyday knowledge, and something anybody could have, even if they had nothing else.
在丑闻发生后，关于问答节目的一切似乎都受到了玷污。突然之间，你需要想出新的点子来做这些节目。“问答”（Quiz）成了一个肮脏的词。它有了负面含义，这就是我们最终得到“游戏节目”（Game Show）这个词的原因。这些不是问答节目的游戏节目在20世纪60年代变得流行起来。你开始寻找人们可以做的其他事情来赢钱。这不仅仅是品牌重塑。这是对格式的全新尝试。仅仅靠问答节目式的书本知识来赢钱的机会，已经不存在了。相反，这些新的游戏节目依赖于运动技能、日常知识，以及任何人都可能拥有的东西，即使他们一无所有。
Luck. And you'd need a lot of it if you wanted to win the new game show that was about to sweep the nation. Let's take a break to talk about our sponsor for today's episode, Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Have you ever wished you could hand off a task to someone while you'd? you're on the go. Claude is the collaborator that actually understands your entire workflow and things with you. Integrate Claude into any part of your project, keeping you focused on solutions. As your research assistant, Claude's research capabilities are comprehensive, reliable analysis with proper citations, turning hours of research into minutes. Claude becomes your command center by connecting to your
运气。如果你想赢得即将席卷全国的新游戏节目，你需要很多运气。让我们休息一下，谈谈我们今天节目的赞助商，Claude背后的团队Anthropic。你有没有想过在你忙碌时把任务交给别人？Claude是真正理解你整个工作流程并与你共同思考的合作伙伴。将Claude集成到你项目的任何部分，让你专注于解决方案。作为你的研究助理，Claude的研究能力是全面、可靠的分析，并带有适当的引用，将数小时的研究转化为几分钟。Claude通过连接到你的
professional tools like GitHub, Jira, HubSpot, Notion, and Google workspace. Build interactive tools and apps by describing what you need. Delegate tasks big and small with co-work so you can handle other work while Claude runs. It even has checkpoints that lets you save progress and roll back to any previous state instantly. And when all the work is done, Claude can help you create a polished document, spreadsheet, or presentation directly in your file system. No need to worry about rough drafts that need heavy editing. For problems worth solving, get started with Claude at clod.aI. That's clod.aI. In the 1970s, the game show industry was moving away from hard knowledge-based programs.
专业工具（如GitHub、Jira、HubSpot、Notion和Google Workspace）成为你的指挥中心。通过描述你的需求来构建交互式工具和应用程序。通过协作工作委派大小任务，这样你就可以在Claude运行时处理其他工作。它甚至有检查点，让你保存进度并立即回滚到任何以前的状态。当所有工作完成后，Claude可以帮助你直接在文件系统中创建一个精美的文档、电子表格或演示文稿。无需担心需要大量编辑的草稿。对于值得解决的问题，请访问clod.aI开始使用Claude。网址是clod.aI。在20世纪70年代，游戏节目行业正在远离基于硬知识的节目。
Instead, TV producers were designing new shows that were more physical and leaned on common sense. This shift was led by a guy named Merv Griffin. And now, here comes Merv. Merv Griffin was this singer and talk show host who also dabbled in making game shows. And for somebody who dabbled, Merv was pretty good at it. He was the brain behind the hit 60s show Jeopardy, which had aspects of the old school quiz shows tailored for the Charles Van Doren's of the world. But now, a decade later, he was developing a new idea that was a blend of luck and common knowledge instead. At the heart of Merv's new vision were two of his fondest childhood memories.
相反，电视制片人正在设计更具身体性并依赖常识的新节目。这种转变是由一个名叫默夫·格里芬（Merv Griffin）的人领导的。现在，默夫来了。默夫·格里芬是一位歌手和脱口秀主持人，他也涉足制作游戏节目。对于一个涉足者来说，默夫在这方面做得相当不错。他是60年代热门节目《危险边缘》（Jeopardy）背后的智囊，该节目具有为查尔斯·范多伦这类人量身定制的老派问答节目的特点。但现在，十年后，他正在开发一个结合了运气和常识的新想法。默夫新愿景的核心是他童年最美好的两段记忆。
His family used to go on road trips during the summer, and he and his sister would play hangman with pencil and paper in the backseat to entertain themselves during the car trip. The other memory was he went to a carnival once, and he was enamored by the big carnival wheel that people were spinning for prizes. And so he came up with this idea, you would play hangman, but you spun the wheel before every letter you called, and what the wheel landed on determined what the letters were worth. So Merv pitched the show to an NBC executive, who insisted on one change in order to make it more appealing to a female audience. She had this idea to do a shopping game show. And what she described from Merv Griffin was, we have press. prizes all over the stage and contestants take their money and they just immediately buy prizes every time they solve the puzzle.
他的家人过去常在夏天去公路旅行，他和他的妹妹会在后座用铅笔和纸玩“刽子手”游戏，在车程中自娱自乐。另一个记忆是他曾经去过一个嘉年华，他被人们为了奖品而转动的大型嘉年华转盘迷住了。于是他想出了这个主意，你玩“刽子手”，但在你叫出每个字母之前先转动转盘，转盘停在什么位置决定了字母的价值。所以默夫向一位NBC高管推销了这个节目，该高管坚持要进行一项改变，以便使其对女性观众更具吸引力。她有一个做购物游戏节目的想法。她向默夫·格里芬描述的是，我们在舞台上到处都是奖品，参赛者拿着他们的钱，每次解开谜题时就立即购买奖品。
Merv didn't exactly love this tweak, but he wanted to get the show on the air. So they developed it into this format initially called Shoppers Bazaar, and they shoot this pilot and the pilot kind of sucks. All right. Now, ladies, remember, you must earn enough money to pay for your gifts and solve a puzzle in order to take them home. The pilot is confusing. I mean...
默夫并不完全喜欢这个调整，但他想让节目播出。所以他们把它发展成最初名为《购物者集市》（Shoppers Bazaar）的格式，他们拍摄了这个试播集，试播集有点糟糕。好了。现在，女士们，记住，你们必须赚足够的钱来支付你们的礼物，并解开一个谜题才能把它们带回家。试播集令人困惑。我的意思是……
You may select any letter you wish or buy a vowel. Now, if you select a letter that does not appear in the puzzle, you lose your turn. So let's continue the puzzle we were playing. The wheel is spinning. And I believe, Maryland, you have the most to play for, so you go first. All right. Okay, stop the wheel. Even the contestants seem confused.
你可以选择任何你想要的字母或购买一个元音。现在，如果你选择了一个没有出现在谜题中的字母，你就会失去你的回合。所以让我们继续我们正在玩的谜题。转盘正在转动。我相信，玛丽兰，你玩的机会最大，所以你先来。好的。好的，停止转盘。连参赛者似乎都很困惑。
They had to pre-select prizes. There was an accounting department to make sense of who was in profit and who was in debt. The contestants didn't even spin the wheel. themselves, they just shouted, stop the wheel, and usually before the wheel even started spinning, it didn't work. So they tried again, except this time they subbed out the upright carnival wheel and replaced it with a giant, horizontal roulette-style wheel big enough to practically fill the whole studio floor. The wheel was so big, in fact, that the producers decided that they really ought to make it the centerpiece of the whole show.
他们必须预选奖品。有一个会计部门来弄清楚谁在盈利，谁在负债。参赛者甚至没有自己转动转盘，他们只是大喊“停止转盘”，通常在转盘开始转动之前，它就没起作用。所以他们又试了一次，只是这次他们换掉了直立的嘉年华转盘，换成了一个巨大的、水平的轮盘赌风格的转盘，大到几乎填满了整个演播室地板。事实上，转盘太大了，制片人决定他们真的应该把它作为整个节目的中心。
Look at this studio filled with beautiful and imaginative gifts, which can be purchased to today on Wheel of Fortune. Wheel of Fortune debuted on NBC in 1975. But even though it was a major upgrade from Shoppers Bazaar, one innovation stuck. The contestants took their winnings and shopped for prizes right there on the show. So there's this boutique of prizes all over the stage, and there are the usual game show goodies. So you can buy furniture, you can buy a boat, you can buy a car. really well with the puzzle and if you landed on the big money spaces.
看看这个演播室，里面装满了美丽而富有想象力的礼物，今天可以在《幸运轮》上购买。《幸运轮》于1975年在NBC首播。但尽管它比《购物者集市》有了重大升级，但一个创新保留了下来。参赛者拿着他们的奖金，就在节目中购买奖品。所以舞台上到处都是奖品精品店，还有常见的游戏节目好东西。所以你可以买家具，你可以买船，你可以买车。在谜题上表现得很好，如果你转到了大额奖金空间。
The quiz shows of old were built around the fantasy that being book smart could make you rich. Wheel of Fortune was different. We will now get down to business here and spin our wheel. Top dollar value, $750. Try not to hit bankrupt. For one thing, it was more physical, require contestants to spin that giant glittery wheel. It felt almost like gambling, like spinning a roulette wheel, with fingers crossed that you wouldn't land on lose a turn or bankrupt. But you needed a little knowledge to solve the hangman puzzles too.
旧时代的问答节目建立在一种幻想之上，即书本知识可以让你致富。《幸运轮》则不同。我们现在要进入正题，转动我们的转盘。最高金额价值750美元。尽量不要转到破产。首先，它更具身体性，要求参赛者转动那个巨大的闪亮转盘。它感觉几乎像赌博，就像转动轮盘赌一样，祈祷你不会转到“失去回合”或“破产”。但你也需要一点知识来解开“刽子手”谜题。
Just one letter left with the ball, $850,000 can you solve this puzzle. Ho Tai, mine. I'm sorry, that's incorrect. We go to Randy. Ho Chi Min. Yes, that's it. You had to be just clever enough and lucky enough. It was a game that felt less like a classroom and more like a casino. But despite Wheel of Fortune's huge, mesmerizing wheel and its studio filled with beautiful and imaginative gifts, the ratings were just fine, like pretty good. The first eight and a half years on the air were hardly earth-shattering. Then, in early 1983, CBS ended its insanely popular show MASH, which had been airing at 8 p.m. NBC saw a golden opportunity to win a lot of new viewers. Alongside their daytime offering,
只剩下一个字母，球，850,000美元，你能解开这个谜题吗。胡志明。对不起，那是不正确的。我们转向兰迪。胡志明。是的，就是它。你必须足够聪明且足够幸运。这是一个感觉不像教室而更像赌场的游戏。但尽管《幸运轮》有巨大的、令人着迷的转盘和装满美丽而富有想象力礼物的演播室，收视率也只是还可以，就像相当不错。播出的前八年半几乎没有惊天动地。然后，在1983年初，CBS结束了其极其受欢迎的节目《陆军野战医院》（MASH），该节目一直在晚上8点播出。NBC看到了一个赢得大量新观众的绝佳机会。除了他们的日间节目，
they were going to debut a new nighttime version that would premiere. year at 730 right before primetime. And it worked. All of a sudden, everyone was watching. There was a stat that I heard once, and I love it, and I hope it's true. In the year of 1986, on an average day, more people saw an episode of Wheel of Fortune than saw Star Wars in 1977. Night after night, millions of Americans were now tuning into Wheel of Fortune from the comfort of their homes. But they weren't just shouting answers at their TV screens. You know, if they had enough money, you'd be saying, you'll go get the jet skis, go get the vacation package, do this. This is Terry Eldridge again. I think a lot of people I
他们将推出一个新的夜间版本，将在7点30分黄金时段之前首播。而且它成功了。突然之间，每个人都在看。我曾经听到过一个统计数据，我很喜欢它，我希望它是真的。在1986年，平均每天看《幸运轮》的人数比1977年看《星球大战》的人数还要多。夜复一夜，数百万美国人现在在舒适的家中收看《幸运轮》。但他们不仅仅是在电视屏幕前大喊答案。你知道，如果他们有足够的钱，你会说，去买摩托艇，去买度假套餐，做这个。这是特里·埃尔德里奇再次发言。我想很多人，包括
included really watched the show more to see what people were buying in the shopping round, rather than how they did in the puzzle rounds. Oh, God, for 1453, I like the Acapulco trip. For my mother, I'd love the Grandfather Claw. his and her motorcycle. For 250, my dad needs a suit. All right, and you have enough for either a food dehydrate or a pig. I can't go home about the pig. Well, you probably could, but I guess you won't.
我，看这个节目更多是为了看人们在购物回合中买了什么，而不是他们在谜题回合中表现如何。哦，天哪，1453美元，我喜欢阿卡普尔科之旅。为了我母亲，我想要那个祖父钟。他的和她的摩托车。250美元，我爸爸需要一套西装。好了，你剩下的钱足够买一个食品脱水机或者一只猪。我不能带着猪回家。嗯，你可能可以，但我猜你不会。
It was more just watch the shopping and say, oh, if I had that money, I would be buying this here. Yeah, yeah. I grew up with pretty limited means. And to me, the idea of having a nice TV was so overwhelming, so seductive, that I'd be like, why would you get a vacation? And now, as an older man, I'm like, I would take the vacation every time. In a way, the shopping round was kind of its own puzzle.
这更多是看着购物环节，然后说，哦，如果我有那些钱，我就会买这个。是的，是的。我在相当有限的经济条件下长大。对我来说，拥有一台好电视的想法是如此令人难以抗拒，如此诱人，以至于我会想，为什么要度假呢？而现在，作为一个上了年纪的人，我会说，我每次都会选择度假。在某种程度上，购物环节本身就像是一个谜题。
Contestants might try to do the mental math and game it so they could spend all their money only on big things that they really want. But often enough, they'd end up with just enough cash left to buy something they didn't really want. Let's say you have $5,000 and you've bought the boat and you've bought the weekend vacation in Las Vegas. Okay, so you still have $350. left. What's on the stage that you can buy for $350? And that's where it gets kind of fun because what they had on Wheel of Fortune was a hand-carved nightstand that resembled an elephant. Or you could buy a Gucci calculator. I didn't know that Gucci made calculators until they gave one away on Wheel of Fortune. Prizes like that,
参赛者可能会尝试进行心算并进行博弈，这样他们就可以把所有的钱只花在他们真正想要的大件商品上。但通常情况下，他们最终剩下的钱刚好够买一些他们并不真正想要的东西。假设你有5000美元，你已经买了船，也买了去拉斯维加斯的周末度假。好吧，你还剩下350美元。舞台上有什么东西是你可以用350美元买到的？这就是有趣的地方，因为他们在《幸运轮》节目里放的是一个手工雕刻的、像大象一样的床头柜。或者你可以买一个古驰计算器。在《幸运轮》送出一个之前，我根本不知道古驰还生产计算器。像这样的奖品，
really odd, really weird, really eccentric junk. And one of the cheapest items on the show was the most eccentric of all. The ceramic Dalmatian. NBC had a team of people who acquired prizes for all of their game shows, so you would just go to the prize department and say, we need this for the next day from the Wheel of Fortune. And one of the people who worked in the prize department was a guy named Sheldon Link. And the apocryphal story is that Sheldon Link was enamored with this ceramic Dalmatian and bought a bulk order of them, like 100 ceramic Dalmatians, more than the show was ever going to need. The ceramic Dalmatian was even more useless than most of the other prizes on Wheel of Fire of fortune. You can't put a lamp on it. You can't solve math problems with it. It's purely ornamental.
真的很奇怪，真的很古怪，真的很离奇的垃圾。节目中最便宜的物品之一也是最古怪的。陶瓷大麦町犬。NBC有一个专门为他们所有游戏节目采购奖品的团队，所以你只需要去奖品部门说，我们需要这个给明天的《幸运轮》节目用。奖品部门的工作人员之一是一个叫谢尔顿·林克的人。坊间传闻是，谢尔顿·林克迷上了这只陶瓷大麦町犬，并批量订购了它们，大概有100只陶瓷大麦町犬，远超节目组的需求。这只陶瓷大麦町犬比《幸运轮》节目中的大多数其他奖品还要没用。你不能在它上面放灯。你不能用它解决数学问题。它纯粹是装饰性的。
But it definitely wasn't a piece of art either. You still have almost $3,800. Oh. For my coworkers, for $154, the ceramic Dalmatian, I promised it. Well, you're too generous, Lily. And to top it off, at more than $150 a piece, it was, like, kind of expensive. and it took up a lot of space, too. He is about two and a half to three feet tall. Wow. And probably a total front to back 18 inches. So he's sizable.
但它绝对也不是什么艺术品。你还有将近3800美元。哦。对于我的同事们，154美元买这只陶瓷大麦町犬，我答应了。好吧，你太慷慨了，莉莉。最重要的是，每件超过150美元，它有点，算是挺贵的。而且它也占用了很大的空间。它大约有两英尺半到三英尺高。哇。从前到后总共大概18英寸。所以它个头不小。
And a strange thing happened when Wheel of Fortune exploded. And suddenly a massive audience was seeing that porcelain pooch in the shopping round every night. If you watch the show in the 1980s and the contestants are shopping for prize, what you'll notice is the studio audience will sometimes burst into a round of applause when a contestant says, I'll buy the ceramic Dalmatian. And not quite finished here. You have 356. Guess what you can get. Oh, I would really love that ceramic Dalmatian. They don't applaud for the speedboat. They don't applaud for the trip to Acapulco. They applaud for the ceramic Dalmatian. It was a total accident. But the ceramic Dalmatian was the signal. enterprise of Wheel of Fortune during a period where Wheel of Fortune sort of suddenly became
当《幸运轮》火爆时，一件奇怪的事情发生了。突然间，每晚都有大量的观众在购物环节看到那只瓷狗。如果你在20世纪80年代看这个节目，参赛者正在挑选奖品，你会注意到演播室观众有时会在参赛者说“我要买那只陶瓷大麦町犬”时爆发出掌声。还没完呢。你有356美元。猜猜你能得到什么。哦，我真的很想要那只陶瓷大麦町犬。他们不会为快艇鼓掌。他们不会为去阿卡普尔科的旅行鼓掌。他们为陶瓷大麦町犬鼓掌。这完全是个意外。但陶瓷大麦町犬是《幸运轮》在突然成为
a pop culture phenomenon. People went crazy for the Consolation Prize that the game forced you to buy when you couldn't afford to buy anything else. The Dalmatian became such a hit that over time it even got a name, Sheldon, after the prize coordinator who first put it on stage. Okay, so the ceramic dog became known as Sheldon. Yes. How did that get out? Like, how did average people know Sheldon? Honestly, this is going to sound self-aggrandizing. I think I'm the reason that people know that now. Because the one year that I worked at Wheel of Fortune for Christmas, everybody who was employed by Wheel of Fortune got a small tabletop-sized ceramic Dalmatian.
流行文化现象期间的标志性奖品。人们对游戏强迫你在买不起其他东西时必须购买的安慰奖感到疯狂。大麦町犬变得如此受欢迎，以至于随着时间的推移，它甚至有了一个名字，叫“谢尔顿”，以最初把它放到舞台上的奖品协调员的名字命名。好吧，所以这只陶瓷狗被称为谢尔顿。是的。那是怎么传出去的？比如，普通人是怎么知道谢尔顿的？老实说，这听起来可能有点自吹自擂。我认为我是现在人们知道这一点的原因。因为我在《幸运轮》工作的那一年，圣诞节时，所有《幸运轮》的员工都得到了一只小桌面大小的陶瓷大麦町犬。
And it comes with a tag, and it mentioned that the Dalmatian's name was Sheldon. And I had never heard that, and I did what any game show fan would do. I promptly ran to the internet and told every game show fan on Earth what I had just learned. As popular as Sheldon was, his time on the show was pretty short-lived. Viewers may have loved Wheel of Fortune, but the shopping round was kind of anachronistic. Its quaint nature suited a homely daytime show. But in prime time, with an audience of millions watching, the makers of the show, including host Pat Sajak, felt that the shopping round only ate up time that could be used playing more puzzles.
它带有一个标签，上面提到大麦町犬的名字叫谢尔顿。我以前从未听说过，我就做了任何游戏节目粉丝都会做的事。我立刻跑到互联网上，告诉地球上每一个游戏节目粉丝我刚刚学到的东西。尽管谢尔顿很受欢迎，但他在节目中的时间相当短暂。观众可能喜欢《幸运轮》，但购物环节有点不合时宜。它古朴的性质适合一个平淡的日间节目。但在黄金时段，有数百万观众观看，包括主持人帕特·萨贾克在内的节目制作人认为，购物环节只会占用可以用来玩更多谜题的时间。
So in 1987, the show tried something new. Instead of making contestants spend their winnings on the show, Wheel of Fortune just let them keep the cash. And as you can imagine, everyone preferred money over buying stuff they didn't really want. We love you, Sheldon, but I'll keep my 200 bucks. Thank you very much. By 1989, just six years after Wheel of Fortune moved to its primetime slot, the shopping round was gone. No more Gucci calculator, no more jet skis or sandals vacation packages. and no more two-foot-tall decorative ceramic domations. Today, Sheldon lives on as an icon under glass.
所以在1987年，节目尝试了一些新东西。与其让参赛者在节目中花掉他们的奖金，不如让《幸运轮》的参赛者直接保留现金。正如你可以想象的那样，每个人都更喜欢钱，而不是买他们并不真正想要的东西。我们爱你，谢尔顿，但我还是留着我的200美元吧。非常感谢。到1989年，也就是《幸运轮》转到黄金时段仅仅六年之后，购物环节就消失了。没有了古驰计算器，没有了摩托艇或凉鞋度假套餐，也没有了两英尺高的装饰性陶瓷大麦町犬。今天，谢尔顿作为玻璃柜下的偶像继续存在。
When you first walk into the Wheel of Fortune Studio, you see him immediately, enshrined in a display case, and every now and then he comes out for anniversaries and special events. Otherwise, Sheldon just sits there, like a good dog. And I, for one, am glad Sheldon's been preserved, because even though he was only on the show for less than a decade, I think that medium-sized ceramic Dalmatian actually has a lot to teach us about this elusive, complicated thing
当你第一次走进《幸运轮》演播室时，你会立刻看到他，供奉在一个展示柜里，每隔一段时间他就会在周年纪念日和特别活动中出来。否则，谢尔顿就坐在那里，像一只好狗。而我，个人而言，很高兴谢尔顿被保存了下来，因为尽管他在节目中出现的时间不到十年，但我认为那只中等大小的陶瓷大麦町犬实际上教会了我们很多关于这个难以捉摸、复杂的东西，
that we call the American Dream. Okay, I know that's a big claim, but bear with me here, I'm going to get to it. Back when game shows first really took off, back when they were still called quiz shows, many of those programs were based on this old American ideal that just using your smarts was enough to win big, $64,000 big. The idea was that a contestant could potentially change their whole life just by using what they knew and winning fair and square.
我们称之为美国梦。好吧，我知道这是一个很大的说法，但请耐心听我说，我会讲到的。早在游戏节目真正兴起的时候，当它们还被称为问答节目时，许多节目都是基于这种古老的美国理想，即仅仅利用你的聪明才智就足以赢得大奖，64000美元的大奖。这个想法是，参赛者可以通过利用他们所知道的知识并公平公正地获胜，从而有可能改变他们的一生。
But it turned out the quiz shows weren't fair at all. There was no true meritocracy. The fix was in. And then the industry pivoted from quiz shows to game shows. No more can-doism and winning big on your own steam. Now you needed common sense and lots of luck. But maybe the biggest change wasn't how you won, but what you won. Instead of life-changing cash, the new game shows offered us our own lives, but slightly better.
但事实证明，问答节目一点也不公平。根本没有真正的精英管理。比赛是被操纵的。然后行业从问答节目转向了游戏节目。不再有那种靠自己的努力就能赢得大奖的“我能行”精神。现在你需要常识和大量的运气。但也许最大的变化不是你如何获胜，而是你赢得了什么。新的游戏节目不再提供改变生活的现金，而是提供我们自己的生活，只是稍微好一点。
If you're lucky appearing on Wheel of Fortune might get you a new car or a holiday or even a statement piece like a ceramic Dalmatian. Small prizes that can improve your life slightly. I think a ceramic Dalmatian points to the desire to just have enough money in the bank that you can buy crap. The idea that all of your essentials are taken care of and you can just spend $154 on a ceramic Dalmatian to keep in the corner of your house, that is a good feeling that you've got stuff taken care of enough that you can have stuff just for the sake of having it. In a lot of ways, the Dalmatian was like a microdose of the American dream. And that dream was conspicuous consumption, the freedom and financial security to buy
如果你幸运的话，出现在《幸运轮》上可能会让你得到一辆新车或一个假期，甚至是一件像陶瓷大麦町犬这样的陈列品。可以稍微改善你生活的小奖品。我认为陶瓷大麦町犬指向了那种想要在银行里有足够的钱去买垃圾的欲望。那种你所有的必需品都得到了满足，你可以花154美元买一只陶瓷大麦町犬放在你房子的角落里的想法，那是一种很好的感觉，你已经把事情处理得足够好，以至于你可以仅仅为了拥有而拥有东西。在很多方面，大麦町犬就像是美国梦的微量剂量。而那个梦想就是炫耀性消费，拥有购买
obnoxious crap without a purpose. to be seen to have the money to own an ostentatious, motionless pet dog. But at the same time, the Wheel of Fortune was becoming wildly popular. American television was also offering other competing visions of what it meant to make it in the United States. Super popular shows like Knott's Landing and Dallas and Lifestyles of the Rich and Famous, flaunted an ultra-wealthy lifestyle. I mean, we're millionaires a hundred times over. I called Les at the bank and asked him to transfer.
毫无目的的令人讨厌的垃圾的自由和经济保障。被视为有钱去拥有一只炫耀性的、静止不动的宠物狗。但与此同时，《幸运轮》正变得极其受欢迎。美国电视也提供了其他关于在美国意味着什么才能成功的竞争性愿景。像《诺茨码头》、《达拉斯》和《富豪生活》这样超级受欢迎的节目，炫耀着极其富有的生活方式。我的意思是，我们是亿万富翁，有一百倍之多。我给银行的莱斯打了电话，要求他转账。
for $12 million from the account. So what? We got a hundred times that much. TV was showing Americans what it looked like to live with ridiculous amounts of cash. And we loved what it looked like. Soon, our new dreams started to reflect those lifestyles. No more consolation prices. We wanted more than a Dalmatian.
从账户里转出1200万美元。那又怎样？我们有一百倍那么多。电视正在向美国人展示过着荒谬数量现金的生活是什么样子。我们喜欢它看起来的样子。很快，我们的新梦想开始反映那些生活方式。不再有安慰奖。我们想要的不仅仅是一只大麦町犬。
We wanted really big money. And so the game shows changed again. They got bigger, again. The settings, the drive. drama, the stakes, everything grew. I think what you're seeing now is just how our sense of what we want has changed a little bit, because game shows now are presented in a bigger way. You have Mr. Beast Beast Games, which is a gigantic, enormous production.
我们想要真正的大钱。于是游戏节目再次改变了。它们再次变得更大了。场景、戏剧性、赌注，一切都在增长。我认为你现在看到的是我们对想要什么的感知发生了一点点变化，因为现在的游戏节目以一种更大的方式呈现。你有《野兽先生》的《野兽游戏》，这是一个巨大的、庞大的制作。
Are you already? Start the timer. Or a deal or no deal island, where now instead of a TV studio, they're in this sweeping expanse of nature. The banker is back with a... vengeance to prepare to face the most dramatic and unpredictable twists ever. We want the entertainment to be bigger. We want it to be grander. We want it to be more intense. And we want to see bigger money, too. Once again, the old money faucet started flowing. I am standing on $5 million, the grand prize of the most insane competition show you've ever seen.
你准备好了吗？开始计时。或者《交易还是不交易岛》，现在他们不在电视演播室里，而是在这片广阔的自然环境中。银行家带着……复仇回来了，准备面对有史以来最戏剧性和不可预测的转折。我们希望娱乐规模更大。我们希望它更宏大。我们希望它更激烈。我们也想看到更多的钱。再一次，旧的钱龙头开始流动。我站在500万美元上，这是你见过的最疯狂的竞赛节目的最高奖金。
This is by far the highest offer in deal or no deal history. It's $5,800,000. In Beast Games, contestants compete for $5 million. That kind of money doesn't just offer you a slightly better version of your own life. It offers you an entirely new one. And that is the point. So not only do I think that America wouldn't cheer the ceramic Dalmatian if it was a prize on Wheel of Fortune now,
这是《交易还是不交易》历史上最高的报价。是580万美元。在《野兽游戏》中，参赛者争夺500万美元。那种钱不仅仅是为你自己的生活提供一个稍微好一点的版本。它为你提供了一个全新的生活。这就是重点。所以我不认为如果陶瓷大麦町犬现在是《幸运轮》的奖品，美国人会为它欢呼，
I think we wouldn't tolerate it at all. Remember, back in the Great Depression, people willing to look like a fool on the radio for a single dollar. But by the time the ceramic Dalmatian grace the stage of Wheel of Fortune, that must have seemed like a staggeringly small level of ambition, an insult almost. Much like how the ceramic Dalmatian seems to us now. Well, most of us anyway.
我认为我们根本无法容忍它。记住，在大萧条时期，人们愿意为了区区一美元在广播里看起来像个傻瓜。但当陶瓷大麦町犬出现在《幸运轮》的舞台上时，那一定看起来是一个令人震惊的低水平野心，几乎是一种侮辱。就像陶瓷大麦町犬现在在我们看来一样。好吧，至少我们大多数人是这样认为的。
As a collector of Game Show memorabilia, I will tell you, I have never come across the ceramic Dalmatian on eBay or anywhere else. And I think what happened is the people who won them genuinely, cherished it. That is something that you can keep in your home and point to it and say, my dad was on Wheel of Fortune. I was on Wheel of Fortune and I won that ceramic Dalmatian. It's not just a prize. It's a trophy. Tell me about your dad. Did he pass other things down to you like other sentimental items? Or was the Dalmatian kind of...
作为一名游戏节目纪念品收藏家，我会告诉你，我从未在eBay或其他任何地方遇到过陶瓷大麦町犬。我认为发生的事情是，那些赢得它们的人真正地珍惜它。那是你可以保存在家里并指着它说，我爸爸上过《幸运轮》。我上过《幸运轮》，我赢得了那只陶瓷大麦町犬。它不仅仅是一个奖品。它是一个奖杯。跟我说说你爸爸。他有没有传给你其他东西，比如其他有纪念意义的物品？还是说大麦町犬算是一种……
You know, he didn't pass a lot down? By the time he passed away, his belongings were quite meager. he had been in a medical facility for dementia and some physical ailments in that for years. So every time he moved, his physical belongings got smaller and smaller. But really, the Dalmatian is, you know, I kind of look at it as a physical reminder of him. And I always joke that he's guarding our upstairs hallway, which is, you know, my dad was in law, enforcement. So, you know, having a dog to guard our house that's a reminder of him is kind of appropriate. Yeah. Seeing the Dalmatian atop his stairs doesn't just remind Terry of his father. It takes him back to that wintry afternoon in the bomb shelter, going wild with all of his friends,
你知道，他没有传下很多东西。在他去世时，他的财物相当匮乏。他在医疗机构里患有痴呆症和一些身体疾病已经好几年了。所以每次他搬家，他的实物财产就越来越少。但实际上，大麦町犬是，你知道，我把它看作是他的一种实物提醒。我总是开玩笑说他在守卫我们的楼上走廊，你知道，我爸爸是执法人员。所以，你知道，有一只狗来守卫我们的房子，提醒我们他，是挺合适的。是的。看到楼梯顶上的大麦町犬不仅提醒特里想起了他的父亲。它把他带回了防空洞里的那个冬日下午，和他的朋友们一起疯狂，
thinking he was about to be driving to college in a brand new, beautiful red Jeep Wrangler. Can I ask you a question that might be loaded? But like, of the two, prizes. The one you have to this day is the ceramic Dalmatian. Are you happy about that? Heck no. I would have loved to have the Jeep. Come on. I was a college kid. In Iowa, I would have loved to have had the Jeep Wrangler. But the ceramic Dalmatian, I'm sure, holds a more dear place in my heart and kind of in the lower of our family. Yeah, yeah. Turns out, despite everything, the ceramic Dalmatian is still the consolation prize. After all, Adam Neediff is a game show author and researcher for the National Archives of Game Show History.
以为他即将开着一辆崭新的、漂亮的红色吉普牧马人去上大学。我可以问你一个可能带有偏见的问题吗？但是，比如，这两个奖品。你至今还保留着的是陶瓷大麦町犬。你对此感到高兴吗？当然不。我本来很想拥有那辆吉普车。拜托。我当时是个大学生。在爱荷华州，我本来很想拥有一辆吉普牧马人。但陶瓷大麦町犬，我相信，在我心中以及我们家庭的传说中占据着更亲密的位置。是的，是的。事实证明，尽管发生了一切，陶瓷大麦町犬仍然是安慰奖。毕竟，亚当·尼迪夫是一位游戏节目作家和国家游戏节目历史档案馆的研究员。
If you enjoyed this episode, you should check out his book, Game Show's FAQ, which explores even more of the fascinating history of American game shows that we didn't have time for in this episode. And Terry Eldridge remains the proud owner of the ceramic Dalmatian, which he and his family call sayjack. If you like the idea of having a say jack in your own home and you're thinking, hey, maybe I can get a ceramic Dalmatian from my house, Terry assures me that sayjack is not for sale and probably never will be. Sorry guys, I asked already.
如果你喜欢这一集，你应该看看他的书《游戏节目常见问题解答》，它探索了更多我们在这一集中没有时间讨论的迷人的美国游戏节目历史。而特里·埃尔德里奇仍然是陶瓷大麦町犬的骄傲拥有者，他和他的家人称它为“萨贾克”。如果你喜欢在自己家里拥有一个“萨贾克”的想法，并且你在想，嘿，也许我可以为我的房子弄一只陶瓷大麦町犬，特里向我保证，“萨贾克”是非卖品，而且可能永远不会出售。抱歉各位，我已经问过了。
A history of the United States and 100 objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Isaac Fisher. Our other producers are Ellie Lightfoot Brenna Daldorf and Priscilla
《美国历史与100件物品》是99% Invisible和BBC Studios的作品。它由我，罗曼·马斯主持和策划。这一集由艾萨克·费舍尔制作。我们的其他制作人是艾莉·莱特福特、布伦娜·达尔多夫和普里西拉
Alabi. This episode was edited by Christopher Johnson. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Mixing by Iver Manly. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright. Artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% of Visible is part of the Serious XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California, and BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful, White City, West London.
阿拉比。这一集由克里斯托弗·约翰逊编辑。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔编辑。混音由艾弗·曼利完成。事实核查由艾米·布拉肯完成。我们的主题曲由斯旺·里尔创作。来自99% Invisible，我们的执行制片人是凯西·2。来自BBC Studios，我们的执行制片人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱，制作经理是梅布尔·芬尼根·赖特。艺术作品由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。99% Invisible是Serious XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，BBC Studios总部位于美丽的伦敦西区白城。
If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. This episode featured audio from Sony's Wheel of Fortune. You also heard audio from the quiz show scandal Senate hearings, plus excerpts of Fremantle's Beat the Clock, prestige entertainment groups name that tune, NBC Universal's 21, Merv Griffin Entertainment's Merv Griffin Show,
如果你想联系我们或有我们应该考虑的物品，请发送电子邮件至100Objects@99PI.org。这一集使用了索尼《幸运轮》的音频。你还听到了来自问答节目丑闻参议院听证会的音频，以及Fremantle的《Beat the Clock》、Prestige Entertainment Group的《Name That Tune》、NBC Universal的《21》、Merv Griffin Entertainment的《Merv Griffin Show》的片段，
Warner Brothers Knott's Landing and Dallas, Beast Industries, Beast Games, Benny J Entertainment's Deal or No Deal Island, and Vox Pop, and Take It or Leave It, which both aired on CBS Radio. If you've enjoyed the podcast, please share the show with your friends, listen on BBC Sounds,
华纳兄弟的《诺茨码头》和《达拉斯》、Beast Industries的《野兽游戏》、Benny J Entertainment的《交易还是不交易岛》，以及都在CBS广播电台播出的《Vox Pop》和《Take It or Leave It》。如果你喜欢这个播客，请与你的朋友分享这个节目，在BBC Sounds上收听，
or wherever you get your podcasts. Thank you again to the sponsor of today, episode, Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Claude is the collaborator making your day-to-day life easier. Set up workflows with co-work to run on a schedule, like daily reports and weekly summaries. Claude can scan your Slack and email to build you a prioritized action list. That's how I use it for this project, actually. It takes all the suggestion emails and puts them in the spreadsheet for me so I can check
或者在任何你获取播客的地方收听。再次感谢今天节目的赞助商Anthropic，Claude背后的团队。Claude是让你的日常生活更轻松的合作者。设置工作流与协作工具按计划运行，如每日报告和每周摘要。Claude可以扫描你的Slack和电子邮件来建立一个优先行动列表。实际上，我就是这样在本项目中使用它的。它获取所有的建议电子邮件并把它们放入电子表格中，这样我就可以检查
them all out and share them. You can build interactive tools and apps by describing what you need, like custom calculators, data visualization dashboards, even prototypes, all without writing a single line of code. For problems worth solving, get started with Claude at clod.aI. That's clawd.aI. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它们并分享它们。你可以通过描述你的需求来构建交互式工具和应用程序，例如自定义计算器、数据可视化仪表板，甚至原型，所有这些都不需要编写一行代码。对于值得解决的问题，请在clod.aI上开始使用Claude。那是clawd.aI。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。